[Musica]
ti ricordi per caso dov'eri
esattamente un mese fa, il
25 luglio, in effetti lo faccio
perché quello stesso giorno, mentre
ero ancora a letto, il mio telefono vibrava
di messaggi che arrivavano da vari
amici  da Palmo in Sicilia joavan e
Alexandro mi raccontavano che la loro
casa era stata quasi distrutta da un
incendio durante la notte e che dovevano
essere soccorsi dai
vigili del fuoco in parallelo da Milano
Marco condivideva i video del suo
appartamento allagato a seguito di un
improvviso e senza precedenti
uragani eventi naturali come questi stanno
diventando sempre più frequenti e
sappiamo perché la Terra, il nostro pianeta, la nostra stessa casa
si sta
riscaldando, più specificamente il nostro pianeta si sta
riscaldando a causa di noi umani che bruciamo
combustibili fossili e rilasciamo
gas serra nell'atmosfera,
ma ormai lo sai già  quasi
tutti sanno che due anni fa le
Nazioni Unite hanno condotto la più grande
indagine sul clima mai realizzata con 1,2 milioni di intervistati provenienti
da oltre 50 paesi che rappresentano l'80%
della popolazione mondiale la maggioranza in
ogni singolo continente concorda sul fatto che il
cambiamento climatico è
un'emergenza eventi come quelli che hanno colpito
Joavan Alexandro  e Marco non potrà che
peggiorare in modo sempre più frequente e intenso se non
agiamo e quindi agiamo dobbiamo
ridurre rapidamente i combustibili fossili e infine
sradicarli completamente dalle nostre
economie carbone benzina e metano devono
essere consegnati alla
storia e questo
sappiamo ciò di cui sappiamo meno  cosa
accadrà allora ci hai mai pensato
come sarà il futuro
una volta che avremo rinunciato completamente ai combustibili fossili
lascia che ti abbozzi i
due principali scenari più popolari
scenario numero
uno con o senza cambiamento climatico l'
argomento è l'umanità  diventare più
poveri è perché i
combustibili fossili a buon mercato hanno inaugurato un’era di prosperità senza precedenti
e quindi la loro scomparsa
ci riporterà indietro di almeno due
secoli. Senza i combustibili fossili
sarà semplicemente impossibile spostarsi,
volare, riscaldare le nostre case o nutrire il
pianeta stesso.  il nostro modo di vivere e le nostre
libertà personali inevitabilmente
soffriranno
per alzata di mano quanti di voi concordano sul fatto
che questo è il futuro più probabile che
ci aspetta okay forse volete sentire
prima l'opzione due quindi l'opzione due o lo scenario
numero
due sono sicuri che la transizione verde è
qualcosa che dobbiamo fare l'argomento
va avanti, ma non sarà davvero
trasformativo, dopotutto tutto ciò che dobbiamo
fare è passare da una fonte di energia
a un'altra, ad esempio, passare dal carbone ai
pannelli solari, qual è il problema
se si nutre?  con la benzina o l’
elettricità un’auto è un’auto e
continuerà a fare ciò che un’auto fa,
a livello aggregato, la nostra
economia e il nostro modo di vivere
rimarranno in gran parte intatti se non ai
margini, quindi chi sarebbe d’accordo sul fatto che questa è
la  molto probabilmente il futuro che ci aspetta
va bene sono
convinto che entrambi questi scenari si
riveleranno
sbagliati oggi sono qui per presentarvi una
visione radicalmente diversa per il nostro
futuro che vede la
transizione verde non solo come un modo per evitare la
catastrofe indotta dal clima ma  come
opportunità per una grande ricompensa economica e
sociale, per questo dobbiamo partire
da due fatti fondamentali: il primo è
la realizzazione della sfida epocale che ci
aspetta: l’atmosfera continuerà
a diventare sempre più calda finché
continueremo ad aggiungere gas serra all’ambiente.
è un po' come una vasca da bagno troppo piena
che continuerà a traboccare finché
non chiudi l'acqua è
per questo motivo che ormai 110
paesi hanno deciso di diventare climaticamente
neutrali entro il
2050 la seconda presa di coscienza fondamentale
deve essere quella  attualmente
viviamo effettivamente in una civiltà basata sui combustibili fossili, il che
significa che quasi
tutto ciò che facciamo, in un modo o nell'altro,
dipende direttamente o indirettamente dai
combustibili fossili e dai
gas serra, potresti pensare che leggere un
libro sul tuo divano non significa
come pensi che quel libro sia stato prodotto
o trasportati da te, che ne dici del
divano, l'
implicazione è che per diventare
climaticamente neutrale per chiudere l'
acqua nella nostra metafora della vasca da bagno
dovremo reinventare l'intero processo di
produzione e consumo,
generazione di energia, trasporto via mare, terra e aria,
agricoltura casa  nell'abbigliamento e
altro ancora, una trasformazione così radicale è
impossibile, si potrebbe pensare, eppure è
già accaduta non una ma
due volte nella storia che chiamiamo questi periodi
rivoluzioni industriali e quindi quella che dovrebbe
essere la nostra politica climatica generale non è
un miglioramento marginale
dell'economia  né più una rassegnazione in preda al panico di fronte
all’inevitabile
catastrofe, la nostra politica climatica deve essere quella
di innescare una nuova era rivoluzionaria un’era
segnata da un progresso tecnologico accelerato che
inauguri una rivoluzione industriale
una rivoluzione industriale verde
questa volta
coloro che vedono la
transizione verde stanno semplicemente cambiando
un’energia  fonte per un'altra non capiscono
il punto confondendo il dito con la
Luna la chiave è capire che le nuove
fonti energetiche hanno sempre segnato l'
inizio delle rivoluzioni industriali e non
la fine della storia, questo perché
generano nuove opportunità per
modi nuovi e migliori di fare
ad esempio, la prima rivoluzione industriale,
il passaggio al carbone ha consentito
nuovi modi di
produrre, ora dopo millenni di
povertà una famiglia media, grazie
all’industrializzazione, poteva permettersi prodotti di base
come candele per illuminare
vestiti, chiodi e forbici, posate e
pentole, ricchezza e benessere migliorati
durante il periodo  Seconda Rivoluzione Industriale
il passaggio all’elettricità ha consentito l’
introduzione della catena di montaggio la
produzione è diventata ancora più efficiente
per millenni i trasporti personali
erano stati estremamente limitati se eri
ricco avevi un cavallo se eri povero
camminavi inevitabilmente la maggior parte delle persone
conosceva solo il proprio  le immediate
vicinanze ora grazie
all'introduzione della bicicletta, del treno o
dell'auto, gli orizzonti e le opportunità delle persone
si sono ampliati immensamente e quindi
non dimentichiamo il nostro passato, affiniamo
le lezioni della Storia per informare le nostre
aspettative sul futuro, la prima
e forse più fondamentale  La lezione deve
essere che se vogliamo diventare climaticamente
neutrali, le nostre economie e società stanno
per attraversare il più grande periodo di
trasformazione tecnologica dall'introduzione
rivoluzionaria della
radio, del telefono, dell'impianto
idraulico interno della lavatrice
dell'aereo, pensateci  questo è
entusiasmante, prendiamo ad esempio le nostre città,
la transizione verde
le trasformerà radicalmente e in meglio, direi che le
nuove modalità di trasporto elettrificate
significheranno che la qualità dell'aria
migliorerà, l'inquinamento acustico migliorerà
e sarà necessario rendere le nostre città a prova di clima
piantare alberi e muschio
ridurre l'attuale divisione artificiale
tra noi esseri umani e la natura non è poi così
bello e non si ferma a questo
già nel 2020 l'agenzia internazionale per l'energia
ha proclamato che il solare
fotovoltaico è la fonte di elettricità più economica
della storia che sola potrà
aprirsi  un sacco di nuove
opportunità la seconda
lezione fondamentale deve essere che alcune tecnologie
si affermeranno come cruciali per la
nostra nuova
civiltà verde, i paesi e le aziende
che riusciranno a farle da pioniere
sperimenteranno grandi ricompense economiche in
termini di profitti e creazione di posti di lavoro che
spesso si ripercuotono per
decenni, avete capito?  hai mai sentito i nomi B
Daimler
Maybach se li hai è perché
li associ a marchi automobilistici ma questi
sono i nomi di persone questi sono i
nomi di ingegneri tedeschi che furono
pionieristici miglioramenti cruciali nel
motore delle auto nei
paesi e nelle aziende della fine del 18 1800 che  non si è accorto
che la tecnologia in arrivo è rimasta bloccata
nel passato ha continuato ad allevare cavalli, a produrre
selle, a produrre ferri di cavallo, alla fine, ad
affrontare il
declino economico, ciò che questo implica per noi oggi
è che investire nella
transizione verde non è solo la cosa giusta
da fare, è anche la cosa intelligente  arrivare
presto e sperimenterai
grandi ricompense economiche per una nuova
tecnologia verde e il tuo nome echeggerà
per tutto questo
secolo la terza e ultima lezione è
che le rivoluzioni industriali
generano sicuramente alcuni vincitori ma
generano anche alcuni perdenti che tutti ricordiamo
del  Quelli che durante
la prima rivoluzione industriale erano persone che avevano
paura della nuova tecnologia e andavano
in giro a distruggere le macchine, ciò che questo
implica per noi oggi
è che dobbiamo intraprendere azioni per diffondere
i benefici della nostra nuova economia verde e
generare opportunità per tutti, altrimenti le
persone lo faranno.  rallentare il
progresso tecnologico e la nostra lotta al clima ancora una
volta questa non è solo la cosa giusta
da fare questa è la cosa intelligente da
fare qualche mese fa ero nei
Paesi Bassi all’Università di Rotterdam per
tenere una conferenza sulla rivoluzione industriale verde
alla fine del  durante il mio discorso una
studentessa si è avvicinata a me con le lacrime agli occhi
presa dall'ansia climatica mi ha chiesto
professore la tua visione è grandiosa ma ce la faremo?
La visione che ti ho esposto
oggi non si realizzerà magicamente da
sola e sicuramente non entro il tempo
dobbiamo evitare una catastrofe climatica
per questo il vostro aiuto è necessario l'aiuto di tutti è
importante perché abbiamo bisogno di tutto l'
aiuto possibile in questa lotta contro
il tempo e quindi cosa possiamo fare per innescare un
boom della tecnologia verde e inaugurare la
rivoluzione industriale verde  mentre i cittadini sostengono ambiziose
politiche verdi a livello locale e nazionale
insieme a forti investimenti
nella scienza e
nell'innovazione mentre gli studenti sviluppano quelle
competenze verdi che saranno necessarie per implementare le
tecnologie verdi in tutte le nostre
economie mentre i consumatori pensano prima di
acquistare favoriscono il prodotto verde dando alle
aziende un vantaggio finanziario  incentivare l'innovazione
allontanandosi dai vecchi
paradigmi mentre i dipendenti promuovono il cambiamento
dall'interno spingono i vostri manager a rompere
con lo status quo e tengono conto del
cambiamento climatico nelle loro decisioni e, infine,
come leader all'interno delle vostre stesse comunità
condividono questa visione per un futuro più verde e migliore
alla nostra
portata, noi'  Oggi ci troviamo in un
momento cruciale per l'umanità, uno di quei
momenti in cui si sta facendo la storia e
quindi vi pongo una domanda molto importante:
come pensate di contribuire a
realizzare una rivoluzione industriale verde,
oggi più che mai il futuro è nelle
nostre
mani, grazie